it's time for drew's news the only news
that would put its coat over your puddle
and with me at the desk i've got two
fantastic co-pilots today she's a
morning anchor at cbs chicago our
chicago affiliate wbbmcbs2
please welcome back audrina biges
[Applause]
and he's my morning anchor right here
every single day please welcome rusty
russ matthew
i love when we have like real
journalists here at the table with us i
know because we're budding and aspiring
journalists ourselves you've got the set
to do it i mean yeah well that being
said let's get to some news audrina i
would love for you to kick off our first
story all right let's do it so first off
we've got the retro look that is taking
over fall fashion we've switched over
into fall here we go the guardian
reports this season is all about meg
ryan people are just so nostalgic for
that classic meg ryan look from the
movies like when harry met sally so tick
tock going gaga over the smart blazers
the slouchy sweaters those tweets all
the classic layers drew you're
definitely in the club you did a full
meg ryan look for your new york premiere
this season so you're for this i did we
ross and i actually reenacted sleepless
in seattle we got to go to the top of
the empire state building it was
honestly the most romantic thing that's
ever happened to me
we almost like you almost acted really
straight too you're like it's you
did you you picked that up because i was
throwing straight out there there was
like a straight come hither and then i
was like it's me yeah i love a good
rom-com oh me too by the way make ryan
where you at girl are you okay i miss
you i could use a meg ryan rom-com
[Applause]
so how do we feel about this meg ryan
look i mean for me i say let's ditch the
spanx for hot girl summer let's stop
stopping to suck in i love the whole
oversized shirt the sweater it just
feels good it feels good for fall right
i've always been inspired by a little
bit of like uh a diane keaton meg ryan's
sweaters and blazers and pants so i'm
in i love meg ryan so much i think
you're right ross um a meg ryan rom-com
would do this world really good right
now yeah can i just add a tom hanks back
in there for their third collab and
guess what the world is healed done
done sprinkled done done
i'm there for that yours all right up
next another story perfect for the
season we've got some chilling real
estate news oh god cnn style reports
that the rhode island farmhouse that
inspired that movie the conjuring
and you know how i feel about scary
movies that house is going on the market
for just 1.2 million dollars you can own
this 3 000 square foot home haunted by
bathsheba sherman who's the ghost who
lived there since the 1800s if my
realtor showed me this house i would
ghost her okay
i am so freaked out
so freaked out by them for sure i would
definitely pay to get away yeah from
that house right there yeah yeah i hear
you well audrina and ross i have a quick
question do you ever have those times
where you feel
lazy um and then you beat yourself up
for it oh yes
so mpr recently spoke to the author of a
new book who claims laziness is a lie
devin price is a social psychologist and
in their book
laziness does not exist they say that we
should reframe laziness and see it as a
sign from our bodies that it is time to
take a rest see it as a sign and not a
flaw what do you guys think of that
i mean
we're so
hard on ourselves and we think that rest
isn't productive we think it is lazy and
we don't realize that it's like the most
productive thing we can do we can fill
our cups so we can pour
into our jobs pour into our family and
we just we push it aside and say oh it's
not important or we're so hard on
ourselves yeah we are hot on ourselves
and sometimes if you have done this
where you've said something to yourself
that and talk to yourself like you would
never speak to another person right
why are we so hard on ourselves like
talk to yourself like you talk to your
best friend with some courtesy with some
kindness some great word for yourself
grace cut yourself a little slack every
now and then
[Music]